he is the top defender available in this
year's draft based on every single pot
possible evaluation from NC State
Bradley chub here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Bradley I'm proud I
appreciate you calling and we're good
we're better for talking to you
we're better for talking to you you bet
you bet so if you could get a sack
forced fumble or an interception based
from your position which would you
choose Bradley
I don't why is that you don't want to
pick one off how many how many
interceptions you've you had in your
career I just have one in my career but
it didn't feel the same as having the
SEC for some Buffalo context where
football is more like more game changer
well what if you took it to the house so
Bradley you can take the four most
announced okay as well so were you
dropping into coverage to get that pic
yeah job a couple of times yes it was my
sophomore out of the coverage that one
off get so to say okay see by the way
I'm asking that just to show off all of
your talents here this is kind of like
the combine right now where I'm showing
off you're all here all of your drills
we did notice Bradley at your pro day as
you were going through drill Bill
Belichick just popped up and just
started instructing you what in the
world was that like from your
perspective it was crazy just because
Bill Belichick is one the best coaches
every coach the game has five Super Bowl
rings there's one like the UH one of the
most noted like noticeable people in my
generation when it comes to football and
for him to be at our project holding us
up it was crazy to see a good experience
and I'm glad it happened
yeah but it's different when you're just
going you obviously knew he was there
right the minute you walked on my turf
right yeah right you can see that he was
there talking the coach door and all
that but trying to make eye contact with
him and all that just because contact
but then he jumps out and he starts
instructing you I mean that's yeah
exactly exactly that's crazy I mean that
that had to be something yeah it was
mind-blowing to be honest with you I was
down at the hotel I tried to try to hide
it by doing the jury right there and he
came and then he came up to you
afterwards right is what he did they
start talking he said he said something
like you won't be there when we pick but
uh yeah we both laughed it off but you
so where do you think you got Bradley
chubbier on the Rich Eisen show where do
you think you are going to be picked
Bradley
oh whatever team feels like I'm the best
fit for him I guess I mean I don't want
to say a certain team and want to say a
certain ticket into like not being there
and I'm over taking it all that stuff so
I'm just trying to go wear it whatever
whatever James feels like I'm the best
fit for that saying well I mean what are
you hearing tell me what you're here
like of course like the my drives and
stuff says like New York and New York
and Indianapolis and Cleveland all that
but you just never know you know it like
I know you should never know yeah how
many of those mock drafts do you pay
attention to because they're in that
great Here I am so I just try not to pay
attention to him but I definitely see
him just being on my phone and stuff on
social media and following the NFL on
Instagram standing like that mm-hmm
because you know I mean you were
basically in the first few mock drafts
you were just you were you were penned
into third overall the Indianapolis and
then obviously they traded out so let's
go I guess one by one here have you
visited with Cleveland Bradley no I have
they reached out to you to visit with
them no I met with him at the combine no
that's about it okay the Giants I know
you you just had a visit with them
correct yes I did and I heard you showed
up in a suit and tie is that correct
yeah why is that all my business entire
just because I wanted to make it known
that I'm serious about my job and I want
to be a part of whatever franchise that
I visited and I just want to make a good
impression
okay now what was your 40 time at the
combine Forrest a father okay what would
your 40 time be in a suit and tie like
me what do you think I like I like what
you did with that 602 but I think I'm
trying to go at least 49 something hmm
Bradley look man you came up with your
first red flag in this interview
unfortunately six six oh two is an old
time
I ran a five nine six this year do not
cheat me on the five 100 to the oh I
realize you're in the five hey you know
look you've been up to you and your own
things I understand I get it but it's
interesting that you show up in a suit
and tie what was the visit with the
Giants like for you Bradley was positive
around me everybody was good to see me I
was I mean was happy to see me I was
happy to see them it was just a good
experience and um got a chance to talk
to mr. gentleman and uh let me
coordinated line that Coach D line coach
I mean it was just all positive okay
have you visited with the Jets no okay
so then let's go to the Broncos what
about them Bradley no sir what would it
mean to you to be drafted by them and
put on the same lawn as von Miller it'll
be crazy I mean Bob Dylan like I said in
my interviews before I'm a lot of guys I
look up to one of the I try to model my
game master so if I get a chance to
actually play with it will be crazy have
you visited with the Colts did that to
combine and at school nothing who have
you personally visited other than the
Giants the Bears and the buck bears in
the box yeah you're not going down there
you know you're not by me and you're not
gonna be drafted down there somebody's
gonna maybe come up and get you in that
regard are you going to the draft who's
with you
who's coming with you my whole family my
girlfriend my friends from high school
and all that so we've got a lot of
people so your plus plus what Bradley
Chubb plus what at the gloves okay have
you gotten your suit picked out for the
draft then yeah I think now a lot of
monthly I mean not much a week ago
okay it's fine if it's a month ago I'd
have picked it out ten years ago if I
was if I was somebody's tells you so
what do you have now can you give me a
little hint what it's gonna be no ok
custom lining is it a custom wine
situation ok shoes you got that pic down
yeah I gotta see you picked out a custom
as well so
you know that well okay so custom lining
custom shoes okay coming correct what's
your relationship with Mario Williams
Bradley we talked a couple times I'm one
of the times we talk about that I got
the number and the number nine of course
and we just talked about two or three
times after that it just all deposit up
he's been encouraging the whole time and
that's pretty much it I hadn't really
reached out to him in this process just
because I've been so busy but I'm pretty
sure he's terraforming still okay and so
what's the strangest question you were
asked at the combine Bradley I was put
through like a math test like uh like uh
yeah like a math test conjure what do
you mean it was uh so I started off they
start off asking you to remember four
worries I just like when I first walked
there and then they asked me like 10
times to that plus 18 then like that
went off for like 15 minutes so you walk
into an interview room an NFL team has
15 minutes with Bradley Chubb NC State
defensive end who may be the first pick
in the draft
certainly for a defensive player and set
you down to give you a math equation
like the longest math test I could pass
to think about 15 minutes straight
rapid-fire and then at the end you made
some to repeat the four words back so
what for what what do you mean the four
words that you heard when you first
walked in the room the first word that
he told when I first walked there did
you admit did you repeat those four
words yeah money with your money what
were the four words you remember the
four words I remember two of them it was
like yellow and baseball did you get the
math equation correct the idea I did
what was this team give me the name of
the team Bradley job cough it up what do
you got for me I can't I can't I can't
give it I'm going to give their secrets
and all that so people know when they go
in a room with the team's with it okay I
got it
can you at least tell me the conference
what conference American or National
Football Conference in the NFL America
does it rhyme with sh Maitri 'it's know
okay very good
geez
would it have been wrong Brock when you
tell me with Bradley on the phone here
if the four words they told me four
words at the top and say repeat the
forward and I would say the four words
were GT f po and then walk out would
that River affected my draft stock
nothing to do with football okay okay
got it
look Bradley you nailed it you got it
right you got it so thanks for the time
I look forward to seeing you and your
custom lining and your custom shoes and
and and then bring in your game the NFL
yes are definitely good you got it Astro
chub right on Twitter right yep what's
the Astro what's the Astro for um my
brother like he really started like
better wild that he was in love with the
rapper future a few dramas comes over
Ashley night and then I saw my brother
start calling himself astronaut and I
was a co jr. and then I really took it
around with it okay what fantastic well
you keep bawling out the way you do you
can tell future that story yourself I'm
sure for you
alright Bradley good luck to you we'll
chat in Dallas you got it that's Bradley
Chubb NC State defensive and @astro
Chubb on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience